>> Martha: BACK WITH THIS
FOX NEWS ALERT, AND MAJOR
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE MURDER OF
FORMER ST. LOUIS POLICE CAPTAIN
DAVID DORN.
TRACE GALLAGHER STANDING BY WITH
THE LATEST FOR US.
>> DAVID DORN WAS SHOT WHILE HE
WAS INSIDE LEE’S PAWNSHOP
PROTECTING IT FROM LOOTERS AND
POLICE HAVE NOW RELEASED
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO FROM INSIDE
THAT PUNCH OUT THAT SHOWS SEVEN
PEOPLE CRAWLING FROM ONE TO
ANOTHER.
IF ONE OF THEM POINTS A GUN AT
THE DOOR.
IT’S UNCLEAR AT WHAT POINT DAVID
DORN WAS SHOT BUT POLICE SAY HE
WAS HIT BY GUNFIRE INSIDE THE
SHOP AND WAS ABLE TO MAKE IT
OUTSIDE WHERE HE COLLAPSED ON
THE SIDEWALK.
THE SUSPECT AS YOU CAN SEE WERE
WEARING MASKS ABOUT THE VIDEO IS
VERY CLEAR AND POLICE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT SOMEBODY WILL
RECOGNIZE THEM AND IF YOU DO,
CALL ST. LOUIS POLICE.
ST. DAVID DORN WAS POLICE
CAPTAIN AND TAKING A JOB IN A
SMALL TOWN POLICE CHIEF.
HE WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL
INVENTORY NUMEROUS YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WERE INTERESTED IN PURSUING
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT LEE’S
PAWNSHOP IS ON
MARTIN LUTHER KING DRIVE.
MARTHA?
>> Martha: INDEED IT IS.
A TRACE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT: COMING AS CALLS TO DEFUND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND SOME
LEADERS IN MINNEAPOLIS TAKING
THINGS FURTHER.
THEY WANT TO COMPLETELY
DISMANTLE THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
IN FAVOR OF A NEW TRANSFORMATIVE
FORCE THAT WOULD PROTECT PEOPLE
APPARENTLY AFTER THE DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD.
THE CITY COUNCIL HOLDING AN
EMERGENCY MEETING AND THEY
REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE TO BAN POLICE FROM USING
CHOKE HOLDS ALONG REFORMS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I FIND
DISTURBING IN THIS DAVID DORN
STORY, WE ALL ARE SYMPATHETIC TO
GEORGE FLOYD, HORRIFIED BY WHAT
WE SAW ON THE VIDEO, THE EVIL IN
THE OFFICES FACE OFFICERS FACE.
BUT MY QUESTION IS WHERE IS A
PROTEST ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
WHY DO WE NOT SEE A SIMILAR
OUTCRY FOR THIS MAN WHO WAS 38
YEARS ON THE POLICE FORCE AND AS
TRACE POINTED OUT, FATHER OF
FIVE AND GRANDFATHER TO TEN
PEOPLE?
WHERE IS THE OUTCRY?
>> I THINK THESE CRIMINALS
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED WITH THE
FULL FORCE OF THE LAW.
I DON’T THINK YOU WILL SEE ANY
HESITATION ABOUT THAT COMING NOT
ONLY FROM THE ST. LOUIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT BUT FROM THE PEOPLE
OF ST. LOUIS.
BLACK, WHITE, ASIAN AND LATINO.
IT’S A HORRIFIC THING TO SEE A
MAN LOSE HIS LIFE TO THE
COMMUNITY OF CRIMINALS.
SO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT, AND
THE POLITICIAN IN ST. LOUIS
DON’T HAVE A VOICE, WHILE OF
COURSE THEY DO AND THEY HAVE THE
POWER TO EXERCISE IT.
AND THE OTHER CASE YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO FEEL
LIKE IT HAS BEEN IGNORED, AND
THEY ARE TAKING TO THE STREETS
IN PEACEFUL PROTEST, SAYING WE
NEED TO DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM OF COURSE WHICH YOU
PROPERLY DEPICTED.
JUST A QUICK NOTE HERE, I THINK
THAT THESE CALLS TO DEFUND THE
POLICE, I DON’T HAVE MUCH
RESPECT FOR IT TO BE BRUTALLY
HONEST.
TO ME, FOR COMMUNITIES NEED
ACCESS POLICING.
AND WE DON’T NEED IT LOOKING
LIKE THE POLICE OR MILITARY
FORCE BUT WE DO NEED A STRONG
POLICING, SOMETIMES MAYBE MORE
MONEY FOR BETTER COMMUNITY
POLICING AND BETTER OUTREACH.
SO TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
WHAT WE HAD IN TERMS OF POLICE
AND COMMUNITY RELATIONS.
>> Martha: GREG, ABOUT THE
IDEA TO DEFUND POLICE
DEPARTMENT’S IN SOME PLACES, YOU
HAVE JEREMIAH ELLISON WHO IS THE
MINNESOTA ATTORNEY GENERAL
ATTORNEY GENERAL’S SON SAYING HE
WANTS TO DRAMATICALLY RETHINK
THE WAY THAT WE KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> HE IS A FAN OF ANTIFA, SO HIS
OPEN YO, OPINION MEANS NOTHING.
IF YOU WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE, GO FOR IT.
ANY CELEBRITY WHO ENDORSES IT,
911 SHOULD BLOCK THEIR NUMBER.
AND IN A GUN DEALER, EVERY GUN
DEALER SHOULD NEVER SELL A GUN
TO SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO DEFUND
THE POLICE.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING WHEN
PURCHASING A WEAPON IS GETTING
SECURITY FOR THEMSELVES WHILE
DENYING IT FROM YOU.
SO I WOULD SAY, GO FOR IT.
HOW DO YOU THINK GUN CONTROL AS
AN ISSUE IS GOING TO FARE AFTER
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION HIT THE STREETS?
RIGHT?
THAT SPECTACLE OF LAWLESSNESS
EFFECTIVELY DID MORE TO END GUN
CONTROL THAN ANYTHING THE NRA
COULD EVER DREAM OF.
YOU ARE WATCHING MORE PEOPLE BUY
GUNS THAN EVER BEFORE AND I
INCLUDE MYSELF IN THAT.
SO THAT GETS TO MY LAST POINT
THAT I WANTED TO SAY AT THE END
OF THE LETTER A BLOCK.
WHEN TRUMP DOES SOMETHING
CONSIDERED GOOD, WHAT IS THE
CRITICISM?
WELL HE SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
SOONER.
HE SHOULD HAVE SHUT DOWN TRAVEL
CENTER.
HE SHOULD HAVE SHUT DOWN THE
CITY CENTER.
WELL, THEN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
WOULDN’T HAVE BEEN DESTROYED AND
DECIMATED AND I WOULDN’T BE
LOOKING AT PEOPLE TRYING TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
MEDIA COULD HAVE BEEN DONE
SOONER, AND HOW WOULD YOU FEEL
IF YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD WAS
DESTROYED?
YOU KNOW WHAT, GREAT EXAMPLE,
CHRIS PALMER.
HE TWEETED, WHILE RIOTERS BURNED
IT DOWN LOW-INCOME HOUSING, HE
TWEETED BURN IT ALL DOWN.
AND THEN WHEN THE RIOTERS GOT TO
HIS GATED COMMUNITY, HE CALLED
THE COPS.
SEE THE SHIFT?
EVERYBODY CAN TALK ABOUT AND WAX
ROMANTIC ABOUT THE MOVEMENT AND
HOW WE NEED SYSTEMIC CHANGE,
BECAUSE IT MEANS NOTHING UNTIL
THEY GET TO YOUR DOOR AND THEN
IT ALL GOES OUT THE WINDOW.
>> Martha: THAT’S A GREAT
POINT, I HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER -- WHO HAVE NEVER
OWNED GUNS IN THEIR LIVES ARE
NOT THINKING ABOUT GETTING THEM.
THIS WILL BE GOOD SELLING POINT
FOR THOSE IN FAVOR OF MORE GUN
CONTROL, IT WILL BE A TOUGH
ARGUMENT IN ITS ENVIRONMENT.
>> YOU KNOW THAT GUN CONTROL
ISSUE AND THE GUN RIGHTS ISSUE
AND THE ROLE OF THE SECOND
AMENDMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND DURING THE RECENT SPATE OF
RIOTS AROUND THE COUNTRY IS ONE
THAT WE DON’T HAVE FULLY TIME TO
DISCUSS HERE BUT IT PROVES AGAIN
THAT WE HAVE A LESSON TO LEARN.
WHEN THE POLICE ARE DEALING WITH
CRIMINALS, YOU ARE YOUR ONLY
DEFENSE AND THE LAST OFFENSE.
SO WELCOME TO THE CLUB.
CONGRATULATIONS, I’M GLAD YOU’VE
NOW JOINED.
BUT IN YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
DEMOCRATS AND THE SELLING TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY, POLITICALLY
THIS IS A VERY TOUGH ISSUE FOR
THEM.
THERE’S A POLL THAT CAME OUT
TODAY THAT SHOWS THAT 56% OF
REGISTERED VOTERS, NOT JUST
AMERICANS BUT REGISTERED VOTERS
SAID THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT
POLICE HAVE RESPONDED TO THOSE
SITUATIONS EITHER CORRECTLY OR
NOT AGGRESSIVELY ENOUGH.
SO THIS IDEA THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO DEFUND THE POLICE WHICH COMES
FROM FAR LEFT PEOPLE, IT’S AN
ELITIST ARGUMENT THAT PUNISHES
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE THAT
THEY CLAIM TO BE STANDING UP FOR
AND THAT IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> Martha: I THINK FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MOST OF OUR LIVES,
WE GOT THE FEELING OF NOT HAVING
THE POTENTIAL FOR ANY PROTECTION
OUT THERE.
THEN YOU TALK ABOUT POTENTIALLY
DEFUNDING POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
MAKING THEM WEAKER, AND WE KNOW
THAT POLICE BACK DOWN IN CERTAIN
ACTIONS WHICH IS A DANGEROUS
THING.
>> Jesse: AND NOW THAT I KNOW
THAT GREG IS PACKING I WILL BE
MUCH NICER TO HIM THE GREEN
ROOM, THAT’S FOR SURE.
[LAUGHS]
PEOPLE ARE SLASHING THE BUDGET,
AND YOU THINK LET’S POP THE
CHAMPAGNE, LET’S START THE CRIME
SPREE.
THAT MEANS LESS SQUAD CARS, LESS
FIREPOWER, LESS DRUG SNIFFING
DOGS, LESS TASK FORCES.
WE ARE JUST GOING TO RUN WILD.
BECAUSE NOW YOU ARE GOING TO
ARISTA POSSESSED MORE RESIST ARR
AND MOST OF THE POLICE IN THE
INNER-CITY ARE NOT SHOOTING IT
OUT WITH GANG BANGERS LIKE YOU
SEE ON TV EVERY DAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING?
THEY ARE HELPING THE HOMELESS
GUY WHO HAS FALLEN INTO THE
SUBWAY.
THEY ARE BREAKING UP A FIGHT
OUTSIDE OF A BAR.
THEY ARE HELPING A CHILD THAT
HAS INJURED THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE RESPONDING TO A
DOMESTIC DISTURBANCE WHERE
SOMEONE IS GETTING HURT.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE AND ANSWERING CALLS FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING PLEASE
COME AND HELP.
SO EVERYONE GO WATCH LIVE PD
THIS WEEKEND, AND YOU CAN SEE
THEY ARE NOT THERE TO BE MEAN
BAD GUYS, THEY ARE THERE TO HELP
HELP.
>> Greg: JESSIE, THAT’S ON